nous sommes dans un village au nord de
kiev dans l'école de ce village c'est la
directrice qui a accepté de nous le
montrer ça fait une vingtaine d'années
qu'elle travaille ici elle est
extrêmement désolés de voir l'état de
l'édifice les bombes sont tombées non
loin ce qui fait que la plupart des
fenêtres ont éclaté ou sont endommagés
le toit aussi a été endommagée donc
louer les entrées partout on est en
train de nettoyer de faire sécher des
manuels scolaires on enlever les éclats
de verre on a gardé l'essentiel de ce
qui peut être sauvé frappant de voir les
plantes vertes qui n'ont pas vraiment
été arrosés probablement depuis le 24
février le début de l'invasion rapport
aussi de voir dans certaines classes il
ya des leçons qui étaient là sur le
vocabulaire sur la langue ukrainienne
par exemple dans une classe les enfants
sont venus jouer ils ont écrit des
slogans patriotiques vive l'ukraine
notamment et dessiner un temps que